after yesterday's ways, I nod was Isa in
Russia even before we actually knew on the
fallow land of the quasi-republics of the Danube and the
Luhansk People's Republic, we, I
khromadsky, are filming the Zrakuvatonian, we
sensed the sight of the President of the Russian
Federation yesterday
and we came with me
today to say, according to your knowledge, you give him a
prosthesis, we will start operas, we
will fight for our independence, for
our sovereignty
[applause]
[music]
[music
] including
I don’t know which great ones will be
great  the bones of their army
Well, in principle, the three of us stand with you
sadkovo Well, guess it will be, yes, it’s not
in vain that Russia just banners its troops under
Belarus pseudonym
you’ll come to me like that That at a time it’s all frozen
on the shelves will be from international spinal
there and there are some meetings like  there are
consultations, all important ones will be dunka
to China, because it’s for you
too.
who can
help less than
him, probably in those cordons for a horse
and are recognized by the Republic of the near-energy DPR
And in the cordons of the regions I already go to
Luhansk and Donatia
on the territory and Ukraine and will be in the
risky path of Yakutia, here already
diplomacy dishes
and I don’t know anything
I think that good nothing  will not
wait where we have already swum we already have such a
mustache We are tired of living like this for 8
years 8 years something like this alive and there is
soap alone I am an old woman there okay But for
children of
8 years old people lost their lives people have
so much oppressive situation now that  I
don’t know how really
good a decision is And how much it can
lead to peace now everyone is very
worried about taking the fathers of their husbands’ brothers from everyone,
in fact it’s very scary It’s
very very very important for all of us
that peace finally comes to our
republic and in Lugansk We  we just want
peace, calmness.
So for us, this is very important. We want
to live as one big family together with
Russia. Before me, to be honest, it is very important
because  I am a former militiaman from
Semyonovka from Slavinsk, I fought a
lot for the sake of this Earth and this
people, they become independent, let's
say that this Earth is recognized and
that people live in Freedom and have the right to
speak their word and have the right to choose and
get what everyone is for  the republic, all
these debts here went to where the personality is.
I think there may be better
certainty in my two
sons. I have two sons and now they are rushing about because of
this situation, looking for their place.
this is the most
important thing for me